[Music]  that's enough I come to bring you home  son  deaths last year  keep piling up one after another  hey man how's it going it goes Brown I  suppose like the world or like a toilet  difference in perspective I reckon  so how you doing it's still sober that's  what you're asking me right now  [Music]  welcome to the family  [Music]  I love you ruby red  Ruby hey hey come on wake up oh Ruby oh  no Ruby  she wanted to be washed in the river  hey Ruby had choices for some of them  choices are made for  who is it  fire with the suspect his arm  I want you to feel what she felt when  she died  Shelby John suspected in the killing of  a local heroin dealer  if you're fine tell him I just want to  talk  [Music]  you must have told him something what  was it I ain't seen  who do you work for  you think God approves what you've been  doing  if that wasn't god pushing me to do his  business I don't know what it was  [Music]  I still got something left to  thank you